[Music]
[Music]
is
um
[Music]
is
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
you
um
195 is the additional information
reports been circulated by an email to
members earlier today
um
before considering the applications for
development i'll just explain the
benefit and be watching
those lessons undertaken by committee
this evening
there's a number of planning
applications which you need to be
attending and each application will
receive a brief introduction from the
office of the council's client service
and they will provide a recommendation
as to how the community members should
go
there will then be given
opportunity for representations from the
group community groups representatives
and members of the public
following this discussion will be held
by members of the planning committee
and also discuss the merits of each
application and utilizing the local
knowledge and they should explain
whether they are minded to support or
pose office recommendation and instead
really individuals explicitly justifying
the decision by making clear reference
to planning plans and recognize funding
policies and frameworks
members of rejoining the discussion tax
offices for guidance or clarification
once discussions have been held members
can propose a motion to support or
refuse officer recommendation if the
emoji is supported by a second member
the vote will be held and the outcome
determines jeopardy decision
so if that will turn to the applications
or examinations
[Music]
the application is going to be
introduced by easter egg
um
this application is part of our
perspective and relates to the direction
of the single story algorithm
within the regard of a two-story
semicash property on the northern side
of dual road
the application has been reported as a
community as six objections have been
received contrary to the officer
recommendation
the application was declared from the
previous committee meeting due to need
to seek clarification
as to whether the submitted
which are showing the correct
measurements of these boundaries as
checked on site
as well as showing details
the outcomes confirm
[Music]
is
in block work
by the window and door of the front
solution facing the application property
and now berlin was previously approved
in a similar position
under planning mission 101.305 hha 20
but the development has not been
available
so you can see the improved buttons on
the screen there the partially
constructed building
this size of 0.2 meters from the rear
boundary
which will be 0.27 meters and 0.18
the external ground level on the floor
of the building is slightly raised
in comparison with the included skin
the structure has not been converted to
replay with present and minor funds have
been submitted
showing the player's maximum height
available is 2.87 meters
to achieve this height which must also
be structured by removing the top cause
of blood flood work
and construction immediately
as you can see on my
plan as a result very well
ability from the original ground level
would be probably crossing the same as
previously
uh you can just see
photographs from the property over there
16
[Music]
[Music]
that's obviously because
[Music]
um
i've shown a lot of close plans the
building has an art studio shower and wc
on a gym with the kitchenette
in combination with the ancillaries the
use of existing triangles
six objectives have been saved from
neighboring properties raising concerns
in relation to
impacts on visual immunity and research
community
as well as other issues including the
use of building drainage trees and light
ownership abounding issues
it's considered that buildings proposed
will be acceptable in terms of impact on
the vision into the area and other
residential neighboring properties
the applications there are recommended
for approved
conditions
thank you
thank you chairman uh this is written
statement on behalf of the occupiers of
sixteen older big present the proposals
state that the outbuilding will project
1.5 metres over the radar that's a
distance of 32 millimeters
including 150 millimeters of roof
overhanging ignoring the perimeter
which suggests little consideration of
spd4 are about 3.9.4 a week ago the size
of the structure including its finishes
painted breeze mark will have the
potential of being overbearing
[Music]
it should also be noted that with
reference
measurement to the guttering this will
impact on our ability to maintain our
health requests at points again
multilingual traffic councils
as the close continuity structure
adversely affects neighboring properties
for the points raised we will therefore
disagree with iceland as a commission
report
we will also disagree with some
restrictions in keeping with other
carriages about them to surround their
gardens given the size of this proposal
is significantly larger than any
neighborhood going around on ignoring
the positioning in close proximity to
neighboring property compared to others
in the surrounding area
whilst one material is important to
races it's apparently applicable to more
than one occasion has failed to take
courts with previous applications and an
obvious reliance on the accuracy of
proposed stories has been given we know
it has been shortened to such
information provided
furthermore reference to an option given
to the applicant at a very early
involve stage implications that chose to
be gone and perceive potential
disability to see approvals planning
policy and neighboring impact
and these reasons listed proposals being
approved despite in our opinion works
with of spd4 paragraph 3.1.4 then we
would request the planning condition to
be implemented that local planning
office monitors such works relevant
status as to avoid any further issues
arising as the applicant's track record
would suggest
the applicant has proceeded with the
construction of the new album the
foundations of which have been excavated
and constructed and the blackboard
superstructure has commenced
as the structure is being constructed in
very close opportunities to the
wristbands the fence will be in the
context of the possible act 1996
structure
under 76 one of the acts the applicant
should be notified for their intention
to excavate around the price proximity
defense the excavation requires in
constructing the foundations of the new
album with deeper defense calculations
which they are
on this basis is noticeably observed
when the applicant is in statutory
breach of the particular act
due to the inability for any site visits
and inspectors during code it should be
considered that somebody sells a list
there has been an over-reliance on the
applicant's submissive documents which
are to have consistencies with incorrect
details
for example the boundary line and size
of the outbuilding are the initial plans
submitted incorrect
this has led to a bounded land issue
that caused a different previous meeting
that has not been resolved
the applicant's site has encroached onto
the land of 16 hours being present the
issue has been skipped over by planning
the report suggests there will be
conditions to make sure the outbound
will not be used for residential
purposes
yet the committee's report suggests that
outbound will not cause any provisional
harm privacy issues for any other
neighbors this means strongly because
capitalism of one officer must be out
away by the vast majority of plagueis
opinions
it should also be noted that most of the
outbuilding development
constructed without truly in one case
without building the courts to improve
plans on the other it doesn't appear
that all conference objections could be
controlled
when the final department first
approached in july 2021 the concern
initially raised regarding incorrect
boundaries an instruction not being
built to the correct measurements a
response is sent to the area of the
property using them the option to
proceed on an alternative basis that
their main planning commission will not
be required the scripture then proceeds
to be built beyond this recommendation
which has led to the current issues and
concerns raised
another point made in the objections
regarding the neighboring trio older
present has been assumed over the course
of report the point is that the gap has
not filled in the initial platform
correctly and stated there was
[Music]
which i would like to take this
opportunity to address
to clarify and confirm that no
boundaries have been moved in my
ownership
planning commission 101 305 election
regardless of the guardian was approved
in september 2020 the bill started in
the 10th december 2020. i was told by
the new course in japan to start working
on the parliament
on the 23rd of july 2021
to convey the partial constructed garden
room has been
in situ and has not been worked on since
the important office's visit
the partial constructed garden room
remains unfinished
and replaces a previously built detached
heart building
once the battery was finished the
maximum height of the garden room will
be 2.87 meters as per the improved
planet motion the garden room will not
introduce visual harm upon the
surrounding area nor will there be any
loss flight privacy issues or noise
issues in fact it will have enhanced the
surrounding area
so the legend one document sp for what
direction designing housing exceptions
and alterations does not specify or
recommend a minimum distance from any
boundary for an outbuilding which takes
the following in paragraph 3.9.4
they should not be
positioned so close to naval boundaries
as to affect neighbouring properties
to confirm the bargaining room would not
adversely affect neighboring properties
nor neighboring
the garden room is at the very rear of a
large garden not near any neighboring
properties thus not overshadowing any
other properties the parking room does
not have any windows to the side
elevations not the rear elevation and
it's not after any labeling handsome
windows the surrounding labeling
properties of ultimate presence in dalek
road are of considerable length with
some pebble dash cast detached carriages
out buildings garden structures and
domestic extensions the garden moves out
of keeping with the character of the
wider area as the bathroom is behind the
house this means it does not have any
impact on the street scene and does not
have an unacceptable impact on the
spaciousness the general character of
the surrounding area i went to highlands
that a similar size outbuilding may be
constructed under political development
rights directly adjacent to the
boundaries of naval parties with no
restrictions relating to materials
you don't need to work using a hybrid
working model because of coding 19 to
meet the business needs of my employer
the bargain room will be used as an
office where i can have a clear duty
home away
also in my own small way
in me contributing to the clean air
initiative by not driving all the time i
have two great passions in life in those
specific goals of weight lifting
including cardio and photography and
lots of crafts i'd wait training when
i'm happy sad upset or just to change my
body composition basically weight
training is my medicine my happy place
my everything i feel awesome once i
finish training the endorphins trigger a
positive feeling within my body which i
can't explain which is so wonderful for
my mental health and general wellbeing
having my own gym at home would be
wonderful truly a privilege of dream
come true especially in this time of
code 19 and variance
photography is my own passion i'm
currently studying for hnd and
photography and having a dedicated space
that they go to photos would be so
beneficial for my studies still like
macro and food photography are my
favorite genres
having an opportunity to go back to my
first love of having a space to process
analog film in a space i can turn into a
dark group thus eliminating my need to
continue to hire the studio document i
currently use
to compare the garden room will be a
flexible space for purposes ancillary to
my home 95 down the road
is
[Music]
which would
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we've said in the conditions of the
condition on this
but
i'm doing the full-time condition so
you should uh review the permission of
this problem
wrestling is the opportunity
[Music]
is
[Music]
um
[Music]
occasionally
as to
how wild articles
come about
or how the building may be used and
i think it's a big point about this is
there's a previously approved
application
which is very similar
and as i understand the committee
development rights will also allow
a very similar building to build same
footprint what's more in height
so the difference is between
this
the development that's that's applied
for here and what's been previously
approved are very longer it might be
so the
previously approved was to be 40
centimeters from each boundary
this is between i think 201.32
and
that's not significant in my view
because 40 centimeters doesn't allow you
to get
behind and through that gap so
it doesn't doesn't have any practical
significance in money the overall
building i think is about the same so
four levels higher but the
design hasn't changed so the top course
of the brick has been taken off so the
height of the settings that previously
approved
and the footprint is slightly bigger
than one square into video which again
it's not significant
and the
appearance is is different
in the uh
the um
topic that the top quarters have
significant um i think it's easy to
persuade by
how it appears on the photos but it's
you know it's still
not finished it's under construction
uh you know and it's just being built
never looks like finished articles so
you know it's a big garden room and you
know
i might not particularly like it but
there's no final reason why i can
refuse permission of this application to
give the differences
between this and the previously
privileged
[Music]
[Music]
statement um
[Music]
one of the things these are going to do
is started to reach a party
i'm assuming that that's not a plan of
consideration
[Music]
um obviously
references
not really in accordance with the plans
um
are not really anything that can be
given anyway in in the decision um
it helps me assume
that the development if
[Music]
um
because this building's uh
the the end of the island so
i think this will try to be their spam
people
it's difficult for us to find cocktail
buildings so i was just wondering
in his contribution
indicated only
aspect of the development that one of
the people equality could find was
a distinction between a 2.5 meter and a
2.87 meter height
is that an accurate assessment that's
the only non-combined
with
funding policy values in terms of this
application
well comparing the
component of development with
what can be done
at the moment will not be significantly
higher than
um than what could you go under
development so the difference really is
the roof um
on top of that um
and it's also it's also worth bearing in
mind
when it's different in
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
uh in what they said um obviously i'll
take our opinions on board
but
what's happening is that regarding
the evidence from the principles and
the potential of
lots of immunity
lots of
light
various considerations that we have to
take into account when it comes to
decisions
on this community
the quantity point
that the building meets the armory
is
17 centimeters to the that's close
but
that not currency
is a lot bigger than only mentioned
originally
in both in terms of footprint and size
the creatures we've got to send from mr
becky 16
demonstrated that he was sat in the
bottom of the garden
he could not see the houses in front of
it this is the same for the people with
uh 14 18 and 93 and 97 on the saturday
they cannot see
over the top of this this monologue
it's supposed to be rendered
it's not quantity it's supposed to be
painted i'd like to see somebody getting
between the fence and the
[Music]
building that is 17 centimeters from
the neighborhood
[Music]
from the the main residential property
uh it's not about money um building
regulations look to the plumbing where's
it going there is mention of flooding
quite exacerbated flooding into the
gardens around it
[Music]
the light of the visual community
that's going to be lost the overbearing
nature of the structure in relation to
all the gardens
close to it
and once again we'll light up propose if
we
thank you chairman um
is
[Music]
um
[Music]
it's clearly not the structure that's in
keeping
with that
in the surroundings
and one of the things that i'm concerned
about is that
buildings
that
this permission relies on
a condition that might not potentially
be possible but
we're saying that the villain should be
landed in pains
and maybe pain but
the gap between the fence the right
boundary and the building as it
currently is
wouldn't allow
trades people to get in there and
actually
carry out the work um i'm just wondering
if
perhaps we would reflect on that
and see if we can get this wage
and that disagreement is
series
[Music]
um
if
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is um
[Music]
[Music]
is
is
[Music]
yes thank you um
just seeing seeing where this is going i
just
wait you can't you can't ignore it and
say it's not relevant um
the
other thing to
bear in mind is would members
be um
if you refuse an application you have to
also be willing to take positive action
for that building to come down
so if you're not willing to
to uh
to take that step and then you should
refuse the application and the final
thing i would say is
that you that the council doesn't appeal
here but again
our our own fallback as is the
previously improved application because
what we have to consider is what
what is objectionable
about the differences
uh that are described by the first
contribution and um
i can't i can't see anything in those
differences
that made this application unacceptable
where the last one was acceptable
i think
i think for us to talk about how earth
would
um previously approved and would have
been
misleading you know you could build a
bigger a little bit of footprint on the
community so the only difference here is
one square meter so
um
i'm really struggling here to see that
reason through refusal so i don't know i
just really got some recommendations
thank you
thank you
[Music]
is greatly increased
so there is a big difference between 2.5
inch structure and a 2.75 870 structure
uh i've got some other uh
busy decide because there is absolutely
no way that you can get a paintbrush to
paint the walls without the structure of
defense structure
or the part of the wall that is an
explanation from 16
because there's just no space where you
could not get
fully aware that the red room isn't to
the side or back bamboo
and then in to building a very important
then we need to be able the bigger
conference is bringing forward because
there is absolutely no room in that
garden without magic life to go anywhere
forwards and sides four hours okay
so in terms of 2.5 meters for the
permitted structure
he's outside of that in terms of
providing the mission that uh was given
previously in september
is
that allows
that sort of attitude on plans and put
forward because it's a deliberate act to
nothing bigger
builders no measurements okay so
in terms of going through a field
we have dividing
we need to lost
they are the two good reasons
in my opinion i propose to reject that
this application or reject the officer
recommendation which is something that
i don't like to do because i believe our
officers work
and try and
help which is the right and proper way
of dealing with buying applications but
sometimes
perhaps we get something wrong and that
is
just changed
with
[Music]
um
[Music]
um this is clearly too close to
boundaries on all sides there's
no consideration to masons
in the
consideration future been into the
residence finland
um but i don't see how uh you can
repeat this person speaking
to change
again
um
[Music]
thank you i think
i think
councilman that
remembers reminded to if you use the
permission
any importance of action would only be
able to take it down from 2.8
meters to 2.5
and he's a collector
yes you could have forced
somebody to launch a building beyond
what they were able to build
thank you
councilman
thank you i think that's happening
how was it
uh
was as much as i
um plans not being followed in
retrospective planning i do agree
totally with what and
council is saying because at the end of
the day from what i can say
and as much of a um
as it is
and still get away with it so i just
think rather than wasting the council's
money out there
on the pills
unfortunately
my decision
[Music]
[Music]
um to be random on the front and i've
just been looking at applications as far
as i can see it just says the proposed
outbuilding will be quite rendered and
my
non-violent brain that means the whole
building
but maybe
um
[Music]
is
is actually quite
thick isn't it because
84 is not 30 centimeters
the long edge so we're talking about
a bit more than that
if you take a block off to be honest
it's a lot shorter degrees a lot shorter
but that will not solve the problem
can we can we not just coming out to
solve that by taking off
and making it altitude like fire so then
it doesn't upset the height issue
and i guess that there's an issue you
can't paint the back of it and then like
quite how you think back
you know
so
so why can't we do that why do you have
to go you have to accept my asm i don't
understand why
does that mean to accept
easily
you know the applicant has the right to
submit an application
as they see fit and whether it's
determining that application i suppose
as well
we have not spoken quite a bit like the
answers
are suggesting that motion smooth
favor and
[Music]
[Music]
um
um
thank you
so as i understand it um
it would be
detrimental impact on visual immunity
resulting from the design and materials
and
heights and scalability
and overbearing impacts
[Music]
that's great thank you okay so
motion is to
contrary to obstacle recommendation and
refuse relationship with the application
because if
you're inclined to pull that motion
okay thank you and those not inclined
[Music]
[Music]
is
okay
okay so this application relates to the
former
department store and bentley's fishy
chip shop on george street in austria
the application relates to this is
large 1970s commercial user three four
floors above grandma or
the existing buildings
comprise department stores you can see
on the photographs on the side
of the slides and the former employees
fish
the
used as a standard trait
this is part of the sound before the
shopping center is in the prominent
location one of the main transport
routes through the town centre and
adopts its optimum
the interchange itself is not a
conservation area the sites are housed
in the settings through conservation
areas george street standard new roads
and old marketplace
the signs also allowed to win the
setting of
the operating list of buildings
remodeling external alterations and
two-story output extension
sorry to create a mixed-use development
comprising retail office leisure food
and drink of uses
the two-story open extension would be a
contemporary edition
and as you can see here on the image and
i've created
materials
ladies and
bonds gentlemen coated aluminium with
basically rectangular capsule veins
the proposed extension elevation
and elevational alterations are compared
to the existing building including fmxl
terraces introduction of large glazed
areas into the brick walls and the
creation of living walls
and you've seen a number of images of
the living walls
from the side here manually onto the
frontage of sanford new route and
grounds on to southwood
access to the seven people also from
southern new york road
new road is proposed to be improved
and with the introduction of a new lift
which will then take people up from the
ground floor to ground floor and accept
access on george shoots along the
existing ramp which will be retained
the existing 60 rooftop car parking
spaces will be removed to facilitate the
open extension of the building these
spaces currently fall past the riser car
parking offer across southern quarter
the remaining car park which continues
to operate only effectively two integral
car
with a new system in place 100 cycle
parking spaces are also proposed
in addition to offers toilets showers
and changing facilities for cyclists
whilst the development would result in
less than substantial heart arms and
significance by the number of heritage
assets including the southwest
conservation area and stanford house and
some of the greatest realistic buildings
this home is considered to be outbreak
design amenity parking carrier safety
queen infrastructure ecology are all
considered to be acceptable when you're
taking the street balancing exercise the
benefits enhance the proposal
the benefits of the scheme significantly
outweigh our
the application therefore recommended
for approval subjects to conditions
thank you
thank you there is one speaker speaking
in favor of
the application um
um
officers this seems to be developed by
the joint pension between works and
capital council who own the entirety of
the water shopping center
the aim of the jb is to transform this
area into a mixture of destination that
makes optimum
place to live work and play this
application consisted in a
surrounded heritage assets the scheme
will transform the vacant site back into
economic use revitalizing existing
buildings and thereby helping to achieve
objective objectives
enshrined in local and national policy
which aims to retain both country and
consensus
the design of proposals incorporates
striking new
[Music]
[Music]
offering high poverty nutritious
development while bringing together the
local communities the studying bills
from the applicant's previous experience
as been carefully developed with regards
to design accessibility functionality
and the impact on the strategic
development
the proper results have been designed
due regardless of technical assessments
which will be undertaken by the african
project
in particular the applicant is engaged
with council to ensure that sufficient
property will be available for both
employees of the property and the
continued visitors town centre this
includes dedicated parking for employees
the new location they're accessible on
payments basis
the plans are considered to be
accessible to all appropriately designed
and will complement surrounding uses
those are probable and increased laws
foreign
will provide a positive revitalization
of the education site and will deliver
significant economic social and
environmental benefits the application
demonstrated the intensive change
we therefore hope members will support
the officer's recommendations
thank you
[Music]
disabled access
widely consulted with disability groups
locally and they have agreed to plans as
a
result
they've added the lift whilst retaining
the access as requested
and that's a big significant enhancement
on current provision the street trees
alone let alone the other green rooms
that will transform stanford
unbelievably there's no street trees
down there present despite the
relatively wide payment
um the plans were the last three the
empty belt is building back into use um
though if anybody had efficiency from
that place
was the best fish and chips ever brewing
fish and chips
um
[Music]
[Music]
also places a high value
on embodied carbon as as we've done with
the decision to refurbish rather than
replacing the leisure center where
possible we need to reuse rather than
demolished we hope this project will be
a successful example for our other towns
it's good that the project exceeds
current energy efficiency requirements
but i agree with the alternative
business plan it would be better to have
seen this project go further in terms of
that first approach to maximizing energy
efficiency while it might cost more now
department savings will be substantial
over the lifetime of the development
finally uh we understand the concern any
concerns about the increased height of
the building um
but i think the northeasterly position
with regards to stanford square means
its impact on um on the light
uh to that value there it will actually
be very limited uh and sanford way is
already by and large only shadowed by
the existing structure and so the extra
floors will have limited additional
impacts
in general the increased massing i think
is acceptable given the sustainability
of the site and the benefits of
regeneration will be improved
[Music]
is
heritage assets
and uh
um
[Music]
i think this is um real movement
and there's a ocean resident
um
the the normal entrance
data
as always
um
carefully considered application for
development i was a little bit i'm
always a little bit anxious from here
about increasing um
to development especially when it's in a
town center location like designing the
developer
and you understand why some people may
have confidence about lots of parking
spaces but they were honest
i don't i'd always welcome the
development deceased to try and improve
before concrete john called by just
incorporating
that as well
and so i wanted to think that
do you
mention those applications
especially given that it's a joint
venture uh between the council
the
money comes forward this development
could be something that in years to come
about
so i will be supporting the motions
[Music]
i think like
chemistry i would probably like to see a
more sustainable
development if possible
but you know there's three walls
so
that's going to have positive impact on
on uh
but i hope the pv panels do get
installed on the roof i would love to
have seen that as part of the
application but um
i think for all reasons
um
[Music]
question about about the sophomores so
you know there's something
there on the planet
this is the idea of something
it seems strange
[Music]
this time
[Music]
and
they have made some comments but the
support the civic society and the
business community that's really welcome
as i said
uh
okay